[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the dave ramsey show where debt is
dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as
the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host chris hogan ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author a couple times over
is my co-host today the voice of the
everyday millionaire in america
open phones as we talk about your life
and your money at triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight
eight two five five two two
five mark is in asheville north carolina
to start off
this hour hey mark welcome to the dave
ramsey show
hey fellas thanks for taking my call
sure man um
so uh so my wife and i are new to the
baby steps we're in uh currently in baby
step two we've been paying off
uh some debt the last two months or so
um we got about 6 000 in debt it's on a
personal loan
um of mine it's our last last little bit
um
we owe about 150 on our house 150 000 on
our house
um and we have uh
350 000 roughly in a
uh a brokerage account invested in
single socks
and i'm just curious what your thoughts
are on on
whether we leave that there and try and
do this on our own or or kind of what we
do
wow where'd you get that
well uh yeah yeah um my
my wife's father passed away when she
was a teenager and
this is this has kind of been in this
account for for
since then basically you know 15 15 or
so years
my goodness wow
chris well i'm just curious whether we
whether we just don't even touch it and
and kind of work work everything on our
own or
yeah i'm going to tell you something
your thoughts are what sets us up
i'm going to tell you right now you all
have been blessed obviously because an
inheritance is something that someone
intentionally leaves to you and if
if i'm in you all shoes i'm going to use
this inheritance and this blessing to be
just that
i would begin to to sit down with the
smart vista pro to walk through and talk
through where you are
but also beginning to really look at
liquidating this
to begin to move you forward to attack
the debt and pay off the house
the rest of that money that's sitting in
there i would move over into gross stock
mutual funds
and look at this as a long-term play for
you all's investments
you've got an opportunity to fast
forward uh through these baby steps and
put yourself in an
incredible position how old are you all
uh we're both 32. goodness gracious
what's your household income
uh about 75. what's the house worth
about 400 400 000 roughly right now you
know kind of went it kind of went sky
high this year
very um so let's play pretend for a
second let's close our eyes and say
we've got 25 000
sitting in an emergency fund in a money
market account
okay okay you don't have a debt in the
world
no house payment nothing
okay and you got 175 000
invested in mutual funds with a smart
vester pro
which will double roughly every seven
years if you don't add anything to it
oh but you're going to be adding to it
because you don't have any freaking
payments anymore
yeah so now your ability to invest as a
baby step 7 person
is going to be amazing how much you can
invest
if you just invested a house payment
the old house payment on 150 000. what's
your house payment 1700 bucks
uh it's about uh 1300 right now we put
down a big chunk
okay so if you just put if you just put
2 000
a month away from age 32 to age 62
that's tens of millions of dollars
just not having a house payment it'll
probably be about 12 million dollars at
your age
just paying yourself a house payment
yeah yeah that's crazy
yeah i'm not doing it would be capital
gains that's just part of it there is no
capital gains
capital gains is not based on your debt
capital gains would be in the you want
oh capital gains on this account
oh you might have has the account grown
since she inherited it
uh yes how much has it grown how much
was it when she got it
uh well it's it's uh right around what
it is
now really um it hasn't grown you know
she paid for grad school
we should pay for graduation capital
gains is based on the growth of the
stocks
if the stocks have grown while she has
owned them you will pay
15 on that and so that would come out of
this but it doesn't change my advice
dude
yeah i would be on a written budget a
detailed plan
every dollar has an assignment the two
of you working together
and i would promise myself with the
smart investor pro i'm going to start
investing in my 401k max
my roth ira max where i get to 2 000 a
month invested
in good growth stock mutual funds
growing tax-free if at all possible
and um that alone will make you worth
tens of millions of dollars
and that's the legacy her dad left her
if you play with this right
now if you go buy a bunch of stupid
stuff with it and you got a 70 000
bass boat in your driveway somebody
ought to smack you
okay but if you'll go do the right thing
with this you're gonna have all the
money you ever wanted to do anything you
ever wanted
including be a blessing to others yeah
it really will and and
just puts them in a whole another
stratosphere financially dave
uh what a blessing you know and it
again thinking it through having a game
plan and i tell people you've got to
have a plan for your money
because everyone else does look at the
commercials they're coming out with cars
now that can park themselves did you
know that dave
no okay i never get that tired that i
can't put it in park okay i can do that
but i mean there's always something out
there the latest greatest thing and so
we got to have our own value system
of what matters to us and what we're
chasing down um and so mark i hope
you'll go sit down with your wife
talk this through replay this for her
and you guys really get connected get
over into ramsay plus and work as a team
and i'm telling you your kids kids kids
will reap the benefits
of her father's blessing to you all if
you play your cards right so i lied to
him
oh okay uh-oh he's not going to have 10
or 12 million he's only going to have 7
million
well he can't make it on that so he's
not going to be 2 000
a month invested in good mutual funds at
average rates of return
from age 32 to age 62 would be 7 million
um let's take it to 30 let's take a 72
just for the fun of it
just to see what would happen no i think
that's going to get us closer
well yeah i know but i did the math
wrong in my head apparently so
i have to admit that and on it so let's
see here we need to get the calculator
going
oh that has to be wrong it's 23 million
so it couldn't be that couldn't be right
but
uh actually it is but um
yeah so seven million because but you
keep doing it for ten more years
that compound interest on seven million
that's a holy gramoly
either way i think you're going to make
it my brother all right robert is next
no
no he's not he's gonna be up after the
break so there you go
power of compound interest edison called
it the eighth wonder of the world
yeah and it is not a lie i mean that
you know the mindset when people get
that light bulb going
and understanding when you invest not
only is the money you put in growing
but the interest is growing interest and
so compound growth becomes this thing
that's just a
it's a big financial hug
think about that coming from the guy who
just loves hugs well you know
he's
[Music]
can you see a dirty look over the radio
you made me nervous right
well you should be mr huggable this is
the dave ramsey show
[Music]
one of the things that makes the dave
ramsey show unique from other shows
is that we genuinely care about our
listeners
that's why we are very intentional about
choosing
our advertisers blinds.com
offers high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and then their customer service is truly
unbeatable
they make it simple to shop for blinds
shades and interior shutters from home
with easy online ordering and
free shipping right to your door and
blinds.com will help you
every step of the way just like they've
helped
thousands of my listeners with free
design
help by phone and online
plus they guarantee the perfect fit
go today and take advantage of this
week's
special offer
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five
two two five our question today comes
from blinds.com
they are the number one online retailer
of custom window coverings you get free
samples free shipping
and with the new promos they run every
month you'll save even more use the
promo code ramsey to get the best
possible deal all right here we go
today's question comes from eric in ohio
he says i understand funding of the 401k
match then roth concept all things being
equal where do the hsa contributions fit
into this concept
if hsa is being used as a retirement
healthcare expense
giving long-term care statistics what
amount of money do you think is a
reasonable retirement hsa
that the hsa should have in it well
couple things here
eric you're bringing up two different
things with the hsa i mean you've got a
great opportunity as an individual to
contribute up to thirty five hundred
fifty dollars
per year and as a family seventy one
hundred dollars but
long-term care visas almost think of
them like a tag team partner
long-term care insurance is something
you want to have in place by age
60 to make sure that if you do go into a
nursing home or need assistant care
you've got money or an insurance policy
the long-term care to take care of it
yeah long-term care insurance is an
essential part of financial planning
at 60 years old and beyond if you have a
net worth of uh under 10 million dollars
uh otherwise you probably self insure
through it if you got 10 million
or more you probably just hire somebody
to come to your house right i mean you
wouldn't go into a nursing home
and so um at least that's the way
people that i know are handling it so
but but otherwise
you you know you can use the hsa for
long-term care expenses and so funding
it
could help you become self-insured and
not need a long-term care
policy oh uh is i think maybe what he's
hinting at
okay and that's okay too but we're fully
funding the hsa
as account the savings portion of the
account
as an investment would really be a baby
step seven tactic
you've maxed out all your retirements
and you still don't and you still want
to hide some money from the government
legally
i fully fund my hsa every year it's
invested in mutual funds and i've never
used it for medical expenses
i was just cash flow my medical medical
expenses consequently i've been knowing
this is george w
and that's when hsas were invented as in
his uh
admin in his administration and i've got
like 250 000 in that account so you're
looking at that like a health emergency
fund yeah that could be
my long-term care policy oh in a sense
okay if i wanted to just pay for
long-term care that's the first place i
would pay for it out of
okay and i'm just letting it grow as an
investment it grows tax-free or tax
deferred
just like a 401k or a regular
traditional ira and so
it becomes an investment if you're not
using it for health care
anytime soon okay and so little stuff
like a deductible i mean
if one of us had a tiny surgery or
something we had a thousand dollar two
thousand dollar thing we just pay that
just pay it
and we leave the hsa alone but that's in
a high net worth
situation and baby step seven situation
that's right prior to that
you wouldn't use it except just to cover
chronic stuff
stuff that's going where the money is
going and going out every year but um
but the hsa
we're huge fans of that around here and
this first time i've ever seen the
question come up as a long-term care
issue
but you do need long-term care insurance
yeah hey what dollar amount is it that
you think that someone is self-insured
what would you say you know what i've
got a cheat sheet laying around here
somewhere on the long-term care
insurance and i think it's important
while i dig that out just to touch on
this whole subject a minute because it's
such a good subject
we're such a proponent for long-term
care insurance without a doubt
and the the reason is is that 75 of you
ladies
will outlive your husbands and so the
typical thing that happens is
the uh i can't find it the typical thing
that happens is the um
you know you you lady the papa goes into
the nursing home
burns through fifty to a hundred
thousand dollars a year
for a couple three years and burns up
the nest eggs cracks cracks and
scrambles in this deck
and so the typical long-term care stay
that's what i was looking for the cheat
sheet on
is it under my oh maybe it is uh nope
nope it's got it's got its own thing
over there somewhere james but that's
okay i'll find it later
bottom line is is the typical stay is
not that long so it's a three to five
hundred thousand dollar
event is them typically the max
it's very unusual to hear somebody going
over 500 000 in nursing home care
but the problem is for most people
that's everything they got that's right
and but if you're sitting on a you know
everyday millionaire situation they got
five ten million dollars
and they got a half million dollars
sitting in that hsa or three hundred
thousand sitting in that hsa
they can pay for their nursing home or
in-home
care themselves and self-insure it
uh and it's all tax free
because the hsa going in is tax
deductible going out for medical
there's no taxes right and so it's a
very very good program that health
equity company that we endorse is
who we've got our hsas invested in and
they've got good mutual fund options in
there
and um we'll do that so yeah it's
important and again if you're out there
and you're a millennial and you've got
parents or
or whatever that are in their mid-50s
please bring this up
because you want to make sure that that
policy is in place by age 60. and don't
overdo it because
your chance of using long-term care
insurance in a nursing home setting or
in-home care setting
prior to 60 is one-tenth of one percent
so you just but as soon as you turn 60
it's like all hell breaks loose and the
statistics get you know really very
dramatic and
increase that you're going to need some
kind of care in your last
couple of decades of two or three
decades of life and by the time you get
in
early 60s the price goes up
astronomically so you want to be
proactive
love your parents enough to bring it up
just tell them hey you saw two bald guys
uh talking about this stuff and mom dad
i love you and do you have this in place
and and if so you're just asking and
that's doing it out of love not out of
greed
there you go robert is in orlando hey
robert welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey how are you guys doing today better
than i deserve man how can we help
so i will be starting law school next
fall i'm 23 years old and my only debt
is a 17
000 car loan that i might sell depending
on where i move to
uh currently i make 32 000 a year and
have about 15 000 in safe stock
hopefully that'll be able to grow to
about 20 before i start
i do have an emergency fund as well as a
roth that i contribute to every month
my question is should i use that 15 to
20 000 to pay for rent
and living expenses while i'm in law
school or just take out enough student
loans to be able to pay for
those living expenses and just focus on
school robert did you really just call
the dave ramsey show
to ask dave if you should take out a
student loan
are you new are you new to this robert
are you brand new
as a matter of fact i am okay all right
well let me
keep him calm then you just be nice to
me no chris i'm going to scare them
i'm the nice one robert here's the thing
buddy i love the fact that you've got a
career track
i even love that you know the direction
you want to go
uh but here's what i want you to avoid
we have a 1.7
trillion dollar epidemic going on uh
excuse me billion dollar epidemic drone
uh it's going to get to that pretty soon
loans it's a situation and so what i
don't want you to do i want you to chase
your dreams but i don't want you to grab
student loans
i really and truly don't uh you've got
an opportunity to look at this and start
to think
you can go tonight i've got friends that
have done this my friend where you're
enrolling and going to law school at
night while you're working
and it might take a little bit longer
but for you to come out of that without
student loans would be a game changer
yeah the um the stories that we've heard
robert over the last 20 years 25 years
of doing
coaching with people financially that
took out a law
school loan they're 200 000 in debt
and all on the premise that this was all
going to work the way it was supposed to
work and life
never works exactly the way it's
supposed to work
and so they end up not passing the bar
and let me tell you what your law degree
is worth then
economically speaking not so much
um or so they end up deciding they want
to
be more of a public servant and they
want to work for the government
as a lawyer which means you get paid
squat but you got
big old student loans that you've got
based on the fact you were going to be a
rich lawyer someday
and so it doesn't turn out the way
people think it's going to turn out
always there's all kinds of different
things that happen it takes longer to
get the law
career started and get the income to go
with it all those kinds of things so it
you put yourself in a dramatic
disadvantage
when you take on these student loans so
that's why we're always trying to talk
people out of it
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five you jump in we'll
talk about your life and your money
it's a free call chris hogan ramsey
personality author
of the number one bestseller everyday
millionaires is my co-host today here on
the air
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
if you're financially conscious you know
that healthcare expenses can take a big
bite out of your budget
christian healthcare ministries or chm
is here to help
trim those expenses and make sure your
family is cared for
chm is not health insurance but it is
christians helping other christians by
sharing each other's medical bills
most people have the means to pay for
basic doctor services but
when it comes to something on a much
larger scale say
several thousand dollars for surgery or
hospitalization
folks are worried they'll be left to try
and find a way to pay for that
themselves
not too long ago i was diagnosed with
ovarian cancer
and they really came through so far
we've had over 180 thousand dollars
worth of bills
and got close to 75 discounts chm
shared the rest of the expenses to see
if chm is right for
you and your budget check out
chministries.org
backslash budget
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
chris hogan ramsey personality joins me
today is my co-host i am dave ramsey
your host open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five on the
debt free stage
in the lobby of ramsey solutions kirk
and emily are with us hey guys how are
you
great we're good welcome where do you
guys live springfield illinois
all right welcome man how much debt have
you paid off
77 000 in five years
good for you and your range of income
during that time
uh start around 25 000 it's up to about
55 000.
cool what do you guys do for a living um
i was a stay-at-home mom during this
time and i worked in insurance and then
talked guitar lessons on the side
okay very good what kind of debt was
your 77
000 it was our house paid off your house
i'm looking at weird people you have no
debt in the world
nope pretty great yeah how old are you
guys
we're i'm 30 and 32. and you're paid for
house you are straight up weird
i love it i'm so proud of y'all well
done what's this house worth
around 80 90. okay and you own it by god
yep
all right what caused this who started
this journey
well definitely our kids we found out
three years ago
we were expecting and that's what really
spurred us on
um in like the month after that we found
out we were pregnant with our first
our air conditioner and furnace had to
be replaced too
sure and we were already on the path of
paying off the house early by that time
but um in in like the three months after
that we saved about twenty thousand
dollars
wow yeah i worked like seven days a week
about 12
13 hour days every day yeah so you had
to get some money so you went and got
some money
yeah yeah that's where you get it work
i've heard
that's fantastic so all right which one
of you is the saver and which one's the
spender
he's probably the saver okay i'm
probably a little bit more of a spender
just a little yeah just a little bit so
it sounds like you guys have been very
on task
yep yeah yep it definitely um
i feel like we were we've always been
like when i met kirk
he he never had debt
and we went to open our checking account
after we got married
and he didn't have a credit score and so
they were
like well we don't know how to he had to
have all this extra identification and
stuff for opening the checking account
and i was like well that's kind of weird
and
yeah he's off the grid
pretty much you know uh when i was
pretty young i read steve martin's
autobiography yeah and when he talked
about never having a credit card and
never wanting one
it just really struck me because i just
i hate the idea of the burden of owing
anybody
and when we got approved for our
mortgage i was like well that's great
but i don't want this
um and we just worked as hard as we
could to get it paid off i love it
you definitely made some serious
sacrifices working as much as you did
i mean that's a big deal it really is uh
what'd you
what did you learn about this process of
paying off the house
you got to do something that you like
yeah and um
you know sometimes you just have to get
past the feeling of wanting to buy like
whatever you want for me it's guitars i
love guitars
but i have enough of those and uh you
know every every spare penny that we had
if you would find change on the ground
it's like never spend found money
we would just take that and put it away
we also started a business on the side i
play violin
and so basically all week he would work
and then teach guitar lessons in the
evenings
and then pretty much every weekend we
would play a wedding oh
so we started playing weddings and we
just worked so hard and learned to be
patient too
it was something that took a lot longer
than i don't know
i'm normally not a very patient person
so learning long-term
setting long-term goals was really good
but but she's really
the budget budget whiz uh emily's
actually studying to be a cpa right now
all right so you know the biggest lesson
that we've learned is listen to your
spouse whoever it is
just listen to each other there you go
very good
very good so who were your biggest
cheerleaders outside the two of you who
who was cheering you on you got a paid
for house at 30 and 32
right yep family for sure parents
and my my brother helped me fix like
every single thing on our cars and he
taught me from a really young age
how to fix my own car and that that
helped out a lot
oh yeah having a car for a long time did
your friends think you all were weird
yeah we didn't tell a lot of people um
and then yeah i think now that we're
mentioning
it to people more they're like well
that's kind of strange well i wouldn't
want to live like that so
that's fine i had some friends think i
was weird when we asked for a vcr
instead of getting disney plus
yeah that might be weird
very cool guys i'm so proud of y'all
well done heroes
how does it feel to not have a payment
in the world pretty great wonderful
especially in the middle of weird times
like we're in that's actually how we
finished this was we got our stimulus
payment
and put it towards the house yeah so
we we had um savings set aside for
emergency fund and then the extra
expenses after
on we just decided that at that point
it would even out if we paid off the
mortgage at that time we could still
save that much more and get it back to
where it was so
we took care of it fabulous well done
you guys we got a copy of chris's book
for you every day
millionaires and that's definitely the
next chapter in your story
so we'll get the kiddos in the picture
for the debt free scream what are their
names and ages
sammy is two and a half and henry is
nine months
all right go henry here we go buddy i
love it
very cool all right kirk and emily sammy
and henry
77 000 paid off in five years they have
a paid for house and
everything at 30 and 32 years old ding
did that making 25 to 55
000 a year they are heroes well done
guys count it down let's hear a debt
free scream
one two
[Applause]
oh man oh man oh man way to go
that's about that's about killing it
right there yeah it's a big deal 30 and
32 years old
if you're out there and you're sitting
and you're going well man oh man how'd
they do it
well they decided and then they made
sacrifices and then they worked a plan
that actually worked
uh you have an opportunity to do that as
well just make the decision
today and then decide and truly get
plugged in this plan works and it's
helped millions of people
and we're helping the young young people
own homes
outright which is awesome yeah i mean
it's
you're so right chris that you know the
only difference in their story
and some of you listening if you've been
listening a while if you're listening
first time today you're just trying to
figure all this stuff out but
the only difference is is they decided
yeah they just decided
really and some of you know you've done
that about other things where you just
decide you
you know the old joke yogi berry you say
when you come to a fork in the road take
it right
but you know that's a decision yeah you
got to go somewhere and so remember that
time you decided to ask her to marry you
remember that time you decided to go get
that degree
you remember that time you decided to
move to that other city and it changed
everything
yeah it changed the whole trajectory of
your life
and so decisions are so powerful and the
interesting thing is they're not
necessarily permanent you don't have to
decide something and
and then never change it again right but
if you decide something positive you
could never change it
that's right that would work you know
find something there's some things i
never ever again do again in my life
yes you know there's some things i
always do in my life those are decisions
i always tithe as a christian i always
give a tenth of my income
i always say for emergencies i always
invest i'm always an incredible tipper
i always i mean you got some you gotta
have some decisions that you make
and you know i never ever will do
business with american express again
under any circumstances there's some
decisions you need to make right
absolutely there's some decisions you
make and you say i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna be treated like that
that's right and you know the beautiful
thing is
we live in the greatest country on this
planet and i'm biased because it's only
one i've lived in
we don't need anybody's permission we
get a chance to decide and try
you don't need a permission when you
used to go out in the hallway in your
kids
to school field trips yeah mama hogan
had to sign them
yeah not anymore you're like a grown-up
i'm a grown-up
you don't need a permission slip anymore
you can just
give yourself permission boom to pay off
your house
way to go kirk and emily touchdown baby
they're weird this is the dave ramsey
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
this year's been hard for everyone i'm
betting you know someone who had a
really hard year
maybe they got slammed maybe it was
medical bills or maybe they
lost a job well they shouldn't have to
struggle like that ever again
and they don't have to this christmas
you can give them some peace of mind
help them feel hope
with ramsay plus it's our step-by-step
money plan
that helps people get out of debt and
get their life
back on track quickly so they can
finally save money for their future
because once you're not sending all your
money to the bank you can breathe easier
when the next emergency hits because
you've got an emergency fund
you can give someone ramsey plus by
going to davramsey.com
that's daveramsey.com store ed
is with us in tampa hi ed welcome to the
dave ramsey show
hey dave hey chris how are you guys
great man how can we help
well my question is um i have not been
able to work since
uh the covey came along um and my wife
has not missed a day
she got a promotion to uh kind of like
um
in charge of the whole department and
she's gonna get a twenty thousand dollar
a year raise starting in january
um we finished baby step three wonderful
and
in jack thank you and in january we're
going to
talk to a smart dresser pro now beth is
going to have to
um do like a lot of traveling and she's
going to be working long hours
um and she she
says she would like me to just stay home
um
you know take care of the dogs when
she's out of town you know take care of
the
yard the house um just take care because
you know she's going to come home and
she's not going to want to make dinner
and do all these kinds of things
pardon me stay home to take care of the
dogs
no no there's no kids no kids
oh no grown okay
yeah what is she making well she went
from
48 to 68
and i have not been able to work i've
got um
uh i'm one of those high risk people
with recorded
and my doctor told me that i really need
to take this
stay-at-home thing seriously you're
you're irrita
you've got what kind of a problem
medically
uh upper respiratory upper respiratory
okay
yeah so and but even when
our plan was i am 60. okay
all right um i was planning on going
back to work once the vaccines were
available
but we've still been able to save you
know about a thousand dollars a month
um putting it in the bank um
and she's going to get this big bumped
into a raise with her
microwave she gets whether there's
somebody at home to watch the dogs or
not
so a bad decision well i don't
understand it
is what i'm saying that's why i'm being
sarcastic it it there's
um i mean if you are it now what now
there's a couple of
caveats i do understand you're not
working if you have a health concern
with upper respiratory and covet i sure
no trouble
but that may be let's just call that um
let's just reach out there and say a
year from now for whatever reason
vaccine or whatever other reason that
that's no longer a concern you are a 61
year old man and your job is to sit at
home and watch the house
yeah i know i know that's just making
you sense
plus i feel really guilty you know i'm
not trying i'm not trying to kill you
it's just strange
i've always worked you know i've never
been unemployed in my life
right well ed here's the thing buddy i i
think you know you being
conscious of your health situation i
think is one thing uh but you have
opportunities to be able to work
from home you've got opportunities to be
able to do things where you're not
encountering other people so i don't
think you just throw in the towel
because your wife got a 20 000
raise and if that's what her thought is
i want to suggest you sit down and
and really kind of speak yours uh your
thoughts your feelings to make sure you
guys are getting on the same page
all of this is the other side of a
health concern okay if there's a health
concern right we're sitting down you're
on the bench okay
i got no issue with that at all but the
other side of a health concern there's
just great dignity and work
there's not much dignity in watching the
dogs there's just not
i mean they go out twice a day and you
feed them i mean there's just not a lot
to do here so
um you know it's uh
no i think i think if i it's gonna be
good for your mental health
regardless of your bank account for you
to be doing something
as soon as you're medically able to do
so with wisdom
right and um so no most the time i hear
honestly when something like this comes
up there's kids at home
and she's making six hundred and eighty
thousand right not sixty eight thousand
yeah that was a zero in a comma
and and then she wants to you know then
she wants you to stay home and take care
of business because she's out there
killing it right
okay we can talk about that but dude 68
000 bucks well here's the other side of
this coin too dave he said she's going
to be traveling a lot
so that means he's not going to see her
and so he needs to have something to
yeah to pour into so ed listen sit down
have a conversation
yeah you guys talk and if you can't get
agreement you might need to reach out
and get with a marriage counselor
to help you guys kind of navigate this
and and make a long-term decision
yeah there you go yeah open phones at
triple eight eight two five
five two two five jennifer is with us
in atlantic city hi jennifer welcome to
the dave ramsey show
hi dave and chris thank you so much for
taking my call i really appreciate it
sure okay i live in new jersey and
um this summer we i was notified by
ezpass in new jersey that um
our payment wasn't being processed um
so i called easy pass to correct the
issue with my credit card
but of course this summer no one was
working in ez
pass i couldn't get a hold of anyone
because of covid
everybody's working from home i tried my
husband tried
anyway we ended up changing the
information online with the credit card
straightening it out
what we thought was for ourselves and i
just went to my mailbox and i just found
out we were
reported to collections because the
situation
that we thought was rectified was indeed
not
so it is truly no fault of our own
um we're just having a hard time in the
state of new jersey trying to get
any kind of public employee to respond
so i'm just curious um what do i do now
it's 175 dollars
i'm going to say the total charge was
maybe 75.
um well um
you know this is not the first time i've
heard easy pass sucks
um you've heard that before too haven't
you jennifer
absolutely yeah i mean this they kind of
have a reputation like comcast
you know it's just like yeah it's like
oh when you hear it you just go oh it's
hard to find intelligent life over there
it's like the dmv or something um so
and then worse than that they all decide
not to work so um
you know work from home entails work but
not for everyone so um
ouch so what are you saying you you
your bit you did not pay your bill on
time because the account was screwed up
you went online thought you fixed it and
it was still screwed up
yes but it kept on saying you have to
speak to someone
um you have to talk to someone from
ezpass to correct this problem
and you never tried yeah and we could
this summer we
couldn't and we just assumed okay well
we updated the information ourselves
i guess we're okay but then today i go
and i find out now it's up to 175
and we've been reported to collections
i've never been reported to collection
well there's no it's not like it's not
like they're going to come to your house
or something don't worry about it
they're not working that hard
um so uh and collection is just
aggravating i mean it may have dinged
your credit or something but
whoop-de-dub-duty it's not the end of
the world
uh i i i don't know what to tell you i
mean you're asking me how to motivate a
government employee i don't know how to
tell you how to do that
um okay you know i'm sorry i'm being
smart out like but it's also the truth i
mean how do you
how do you get somebody who can't lose
their job for incompetence to work
yes um i'm i'm being feeling very
frustrated yeah i'm angry
yeah i get you i'm so uh
or you know i mean it'd be okay if they
said look uh
we're not gonna charge you anything
because we're not getting our work done
over here that's different
but instead they're like trying to ding
you like triple for for this thing
so um i don't know what i would do in
this situation is i would just continue
to be a bother to them
until i got it fixed and i don't know i
mean you know just like every morning i
gotta get up i gotta make my easy pass
call
and then we'll go on with the rest of
our day until we get somebody with a
brain
plug two brain cells to rub together to
try to get our way work through this
problem and get this charge removed
down to the original charge and then get
it paid i don't know what else to tell
you i don't have a good answer for you
but i do share your frustration you can
tell
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
[Applause]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the dave ramsey show where debt is
dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status
symbol of choice i am dave ramsey your
host thank you for joining us america
open phones a triple eight
eight two five five two two five chris
hogan is my co-host today
ramsey personality and author of the
number one best-selling book
every day millionaires again the number
here triple eight eight two five
five two two five ashley's in knoxville
hey ashley welcome to the dave ramsey
show
hey dave and chris thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
um i was just trying to get a little bit
of guidance
um long story short i am the only child
my parents were divorced
my dad never remarried he is looking to
retire in may and he doesn't he's a very
simple man
very old school um he
doesn't have any debt he has
money put back in his bank account so
whenever he draws social security he
thinks that he's going to be fine with
that
and he wants me he wants to leave me his
401k
um i am on your plan i'm on baby step 2
and i've paid off like 7 800
since july and i'm trying to be very
smart as far as
if he needs it in the future maybe try
to find some way to make it grow
to take care of him possibly or you know
maybe
make it useful for him in a different
way if he needs it
okay so he's retiring and how much is in
his 401k
um around 140 000. okay
and how much does he have in the bank
um about 20 000. okay
okay and so in his mind he doesn't want
to touch the 401k he just wants to leave
that all to you
that's yeah and you you try to talk to
him about it but like i said he's very
simple
um he doesn't take trips he doesn't buy
a lot of stuff
what he does buy he pays cash for but
it's not
often right okay
well i mean i would just roll it to a
401k in some good mutual funds if i were
him
and he can name you as the beneficiary
and if he doesn't use it it can go to
you
but it's there until his death if he
needs it yeah it can do both things
actually
yeah i was just kind of curious as far
because like
my he doesn't i'm a nurse and whenever
he gets to the point where he needs care
he wants me to do that and i understand
and so i want to be able to have the
money there
to use that if he needs it especially
yeah well it'll be
it'll be in an ira and a mutual fund and
you could just pull out
whatever you needed he can name you the
beneficiary he also
should do a will and he could name you
he could name you special power of
attorney where if he was incapacitated
and you were nursing him and taking care
of him let's say he had a dementia
diagnosis or something like that
then you could take over his business
affairs and manage the money for his
care
which is your concern and uh yeah and
then you know and
if it all works out the way he thinks
and there's still a hundred thousand or
two hundred thousand laying there when
he dies
it can go to you there's nothing wrong
with that but your point is is
that he he really can't give it to you
prior to death there's not a vehicle
that allows him to do that
right he can just name a beneficiary on
it also upon death
but then you've just got he makes
decisions with his life up until then
that either use that money or don't use
that money right
exactly yeah yep that's fairly easy i
mean
the thing is it can be sitting there for
him and if he doesn't use it like he
says
it can go to you that's right no that's
such a big deal
and having that we talked about that in
our staff meeting today dave
uh with uh the beneficiaries please
please please make sure you all are
updating these
uh people go through life changes and
stages just make sure because that that
designation of beneficiary can
outweigh a will uh so please make sure
yeah and so you want to make sure on
your life insurance on your 401ks your
iras that that's updated
and is the way it needs to be uh it's
just a good thing year in to just begin
to look at and always
update it yeah i mean we were i couldn't
believe that how
few people had uh current beneficiary
status in our company
right i'm about to chew on somebody i
mean it was like half of them man it was
crazy because the other day
were you on the air with me with that
lady called or was it hey yo no a.o was
on
ao man she called she they've been
married seven years she
her husband had two hundred thousand
dollars in his 401k he's 32 years old
had two little babies and he got killed
in a car wreck
and the beneficiary on the 401k for her
husband
his dad because he never forgot he never
changed that for seven years of marriage
he never went back and changed it after
he got married please tell me the dad
did the right thing
he did okay but guess what dad got 200
grand
in an inherited ira in order to give it
to somebody he's got to work through
gift tax issues and tax issues as well
yes
and so net of taxes she would have had
taxes on it anyway
probably depending on how it was set up
but oh my gosh the whole thing's just a
tangle mess because you didn't go do
your beneficiaries
you've got to do your dadgum paperwork
people because it ends up costing
everybody that's left behind
money and hassle and a pain yeah and
you're right dad
thank god would stand up i mean what if
it's one of these toxic situations yeah
he's like no i never liked you to start
with and he just keeps at 200 grand you
know
because because he there's in squats you
can do about it
it's straight up i mean it's a
designated beneficiary there's no will
that intercepts that
so sierra is with us sierra
is in columbus ohio hi sierra how are
you
hi good how are you david chris better
than we deserve how can we help
hey i wanted to ask questions i often
hear you say
sell the car i'm looking at about 200
000 in debt
not including the house our income
is just over a hundred thousand um
most half of that debt is student loan
debt um but we
do have about fifty thousand wrapped up
in um
car debt do we sell both cars and get
two cheap ones do we sell one car
what are we looking at to attack this
set what do you owe on the two cars
there's 50 total break it down
uh so we owe 25 on one
25. okay so yeah
yes but the one is upside down yeah well
yeah
so the deal is this one-fourth of your
debt
is cars
it will speed up to move way down in car
i mean you get your two five thousand
dollar cars and pay them off it'll speed
this process up considerable
and uh how old are you guys yes
um i'm i'm in my 30s uh my husband is
significantly older though so he's an
assistant
the advantage of doing this is twofold
one is it cleans up the mathematics and
allows you to move forward getting out
of debt much faster
the other advantage is is you are
screaming at the person in your mirror
that when you bought these cars it was
stupid
by selling them absolutely you are
permanently changing the groove in your
brain
i mean you can say this was dumb and pay
them off but when you sell them
you're saying this was dumb that's right
and it changes as you go you remember
that time
that we had two hundred thousand dollars
in debt and we got rid of fifty thousand
cars we're not going back there
never ever again you know but if you if
you you can work your way out of it
you got you know how fast how long does
it take to pay off a hundred grand
or 200 grand making 100 if you do it in
50 000 it's four years if you do it in
75 000 it's three years yep
you get a bird scooter and a skateboard
and start
moving stuff changes today sierra
seriously
get your life back get your life back
bird scooter you got to be ashamed of
yourself
we need to get some dave let's ride no
no no no me and you on bird skaters
that's not a good idea this is the dave
ramsey show
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country or have a
better life
the army national guard can help get you
there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits secure your future today
visit nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
only two days left to enter the ramsey
christmas cash giveaway could be your
chance to win our grand prize of five
thousand dollars
you can enter daily to increase your
chances of winning at daveramsey.com
giveaway it gets even better you can now
pick up our life-changing books and kids
products
for about ninety percent off on a lot of
them this is the week-long
green monday sale you can get deals
on books like chris hogan's number one
best seller
every day millionaires or my total money
makeover
all of our main best-selling books are
10
each 2020 was the dumpster fire year
but next year doesn't have to be you can
use this as your reset right
that's right you can go i get a fresh
start i'm going going new
gonna i'm gonna be the third pig the one
in the brick house
so when the big bad wolf comes i don't
get blown over right
and i got to get prepared i got to get
my emergency fund i got to get out of
debt i got to get on a budget
we can show you how enter to win some
cash and save some money
green monday sale which runs all week
we have these one-day sales that run all
week i have not figured the logistics
out on that exactly but
apparently it's a marketing thing so
check it out daveramsey.com
giveaway daveramsey.com giveaway david
is in miami hi david welcome to the dave
ramsey show
oh hey i'm i'm doing good how are you
guys doing today
better than i deserve man how can we
help you
so uh i've i'm
kind of holding my back i i was proposed
an offer
on a startup uh startup tech company
and lately this year has been pretty
you know blessed i uh made some good
money
and i was starting you know been
following
all your shows on youtube and i was
about to attack you know all my debt
that i have on my credit cards
and my loans and now this proposal came
up
and i don't know if i should jump on
that first or pay my debt
i'm like i'm like i'm a little scared
what to do
well how much debt do you have david
um so i have in credit card debts
just around 25k okay uh
and then i mean i have my personal auto
loan
that i have how much around around 50.
yo 50 000 on your car correct
and then my wife has a lease what's your
household income
um i want to say around 250. and how
much money do you have in the bank or
you said you've got some money laying
around
how much you got laying around yeah i've
got like around
240 sitting in the bank how much is this
investment
it's around 100k okay did i miss
something because you said 50 on the car
25 on the credit card that's 75 and 100k
is 175 but you got 250 in the bank
correct but the thing is like with what
i do i kind of
work on a commission base so
that money can't always it always
fluctuates
depending on the market too right so
that's why if i'm in your shoes david
i'm going to go with the known not the
unknown
your income fluctuates so the known
thing that happens
you know that there's credit card
statements coming in every single month
you know that there's car payments that
are due every single month
and you've got a lease payment due every
single month so
i'm gonna do the thing to give me a
raise okay
and and trust me dave and i have worked
with nfl players pro
athletes entertainers everybody comes to
us and tells us about these ideas and
concepts
rarely do they ever talk about the ones
that went south
and so i would take care i would clean
up your personal situation
and then give yourself that peace of
mind before i drop a hundred a grand in
a startup
i'm gonna have two million dollars in
mutual funds my house is gonna be paid
off and everything else is gonna be paid
off
because that basically is money you're
dropping on the roulette table hoping
you hit a number
right now that makes sense it's an uber
high risk play you understand that
i'm not 100 that's why i'm very like uh
worried what to do
yeah but 100 of the time you pay off
that car you no longer have a car
payment that's exactly right
that statement's not coming in and now
you can redirect that money
and again it's just a smarter play and
again i i understand the
that sentiment i can go back to my pd
days now listen
you already knew you just wanted
somebody tell you
it was bothering you you were stressed
this didn't feel right to you you
already knew before you called us this
was a bad play yep
so don't do it and proud of you for
reaching out every time the bell rings
answer the bell when you get a feeling
that's called god's spirit whispering to
you don't do it fool
every time i go against a don't do it
for a whisper i find out i'm a fool
i mean we've all had that no we are i
knew i shouldn't
i knew i just had a feeling how many
times have we said that to ourselves all
of us do it man it ain't just you david
we all have had that experience and
but but it looks glittery it looks shiny
yep and then three years later you go oh
god i'm an idiot
well you know though i've decided that
dave we should go back and count the
things
i know we shouldn't i don't want to
count the things i have done no
that we didn't do it's a long list that
we protected ourselves from oh the
things we didn't do yes
see it might be a longer list well
that's true but
we staying on the plan uh david i'm
going to tell you buddy
i don't care what offer comes your way
you're going to do the thing that's
known
and the stable for yourself and your
future proverbs says the wise
see danger and hide themselves the
simple
see danger proceed on and are punished
for it
and that's what we're talking about and
i have been the simple
and sometimes i've been the wise and so
you know what we're saying is you
that that feeling that sense you had is
very very accurate
so well done sir well done man you're
making some great
money congratulations mike is with us
mike is in
pittsburgh hey mike welcome to the dave
ramsey show
hello thank you for taking uh my call
sure
just i'm looking for some guidance our
family
to start off has been blessed
financially so it's a good call
but um i have four kids my oldest has
just graduated college
yay um and she's gonna come back home
and work at a job for a couple years
um it's what she wants to do and then
she's going to move on
okay um so here's my question now i have
saved
all my kids have college education so
she she's graduating debt-free
so she'll be 21 debt free but i do have
some investments that i started when
when she was younger with u.s savings
bonds and then
i have an utma uh account uh for her
so all together i have about fifty
thousand dollars for her
um well i'm not sure exactly
i know when she's 21 she's supposed to
you know i don't she does not know about
it yet but uh
i i hate to just give her this money um
is there something
you know that i saved for her uh
any kind of and then she wants to get a
car but i refuse to let her
get a car loan i didn't know he used
that money to get her car
and then the last thing of all that is
now she's living i want her to get used
to
paying bills and stuff so i didn't know
if i just make do i charge her rent
collect it and then give it to her when
whenever she moves in two years
but what what can i do with that money
now all my kids are i'm gonna have that
same thing with all four kids hopefully
yeah um so i just wanna get your
guidance on that okay
uh well there's several subjects going
on here and i have every one of those
subjects with my kids
and my kids are now in their 30s okay
one's 29 and the rest of them are 30s
and they're all married and grandbabies
and all kinds of good stuff happen
now so uh all uh two of mine
never came back home they didn't want to
they were mad at us they just had other
plans right one of them just got married
right out of school or just before
getting out of school so
rachel winston got married right before
graduation so they obviously weren't
going to live with us or not obviously
but they chose
they were able to my oldest when she did
move back in with us after college
but we didn't want her to stay a long
time
just long enough to get situated she
stayed about three months
and the reason we didn't want her to
stay longer than about three months
assuming
that there wasn't some kind of a problem
in her life
and there wasn't she was a very healthy
and everything was fine and making good
money and
just like yours is something happens
when they have to turn off the lights in
their own place and buy their own
groceries for their own refrigerator
and pay the bill or it gets cut off kind
of thing
and just even with a responsible kid
something happens developmentally
they like to finish the last step into
adulthood i wouldn't let her stay there
two years
i don't think it's wise from a
developmental standpoint i think she
needs to move on with her life
now a few months is fine that's okay and
yes i would talk to her about this money
and talk to her about how to wisely use
this money that you've got as a blessing
and buy a car out of it help her go show
her how to buy a car go with her
teach her how to buy a car dad it's one
good thing dads can do
right and so uh just walk along with
that that's exactly how we did it
but you're trying to help them launch
not trying to run an economic
model there's a difference this is the
dave ramsey show
one of the things that makes the dave
ramsey show unique from other shows
is that we genuinely care about our
listeners
that's why we are very intentional about
choosing
our advertisers blinds.com
offers high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and then their customer service is truly
unbeatable
they make it simple to shop for blinds
shades and interior shutters from home
with easy online ordering and
free shipping right to your door and
blinds.com
will help you every step of the way just
like they've helped
thousands of my listeners with free
design
help by phone and online plus they
guarantee the perfect fit go today
and take advantage of this week's
special offer
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free states richard's with us hey
richard how are you man
i'm all right in yourself better than i
deserve where do you live
los angeles oh welcome to nashville a
bit of a haul over here to do a
debt-free scream huh
yep how much did you pay off uh just
about forty thousand dollars
cool and how long did this take uh 20
months good for you
and your range of income during that
time uh between
55 and probably about 90 this year
okay good what do you do for a living i
am in
um supply chain aerospace oh excellent
yeah good that's a great career
yeah zoom zoom you can go up man fast
yeah yeah and you are you've gone up a
bunch in 20 months
yeah i mean there's a lot of um a lot of
that has to do with the side hustles but
i guess we'll
talk about that okay what are the side
hustles um
i did uh you know like food deliveries
and things like that
um i'll spare you guys the names they
don't they don't pay me to
give them free uh advertising they don't
they don't they don't pay
the richard endorsement fee all right
how many side hustles did you have
though
um probably throughout this whole thing
probably about five
wow okay okay so you got serious yes
okay so what was the debt you just
deleted out of your life uh
part of it was uh consumer debt it was
five thousand dollars in consumer debt
okay um
just a little over 34 000 in student
loans wow
wow what happened 20 months ago set you
on fire man
uh well it actually all began in um
at the end of 2017 i was at work one day
and one of my co-workers uh he just i
walked in and he was watching one of
your
your uh shows and he said hey you know
rich i think you should uh
you should check this guy out he seems
like this is something you'd be
interested in
so that next morning while i was cooking
breakfast i just
decided to put you up on on youtube and
you you were describing
how to um invest 100 a month
and become a millionaire over time
at the time i was also in a finance
class in my undergrad
and i was learning about the i had a
financial calculator i was learning
about the present
value and all of that and yeah so i was
punching in the numbers
as as you were describing it and uh sure
sure enough it it came out to a little
over a million dollars
um so from then i knew like okay
this guy knows what he's talking about
and so i was i was all in
um from then 2018 came around
i had a goal of i had two goals um
beginning to pay off some some debt
and the other goal was to save up money
on some trips that i had planned for the
end of 2018
and through 2019. um so beginning of
2018 came
i started started with the program just
to get rid of the
consumer debt the five thousand dollars
um
six months it it it worked i was like
okay
this works but i still wasn't 100
convinced so
i said okay if it worked for the 5000
let's see if it works for
for me to be able to save up to go on
the trips that i had planned
so i used the same principles to um
to basically save up for the trips that
i had planned
um six months later december 2018
it worked i had enough money to be able
to if i had like five trips i was going
on
um beginning in mexico going to japan at
uh
the end of 2018. so
once once i saw that it worked i said
okay 2019 is game over
yeah i'm i'm all in knock it out knock
it out so
um so i like i said i was headed to
japan
at the end of 2018 i made my first uh
payment on my student loans i had about
34
000 left on that before i got on the
plane i said i'm making this first
payment that way
as soon as i touch down back in los
angeles i'm going to be
going from there um then most of 2019
was all
just payments every single month back to
back i got used to it
um paid off probably about 15 grand in
2019.
wow um just you know just steadily a
little over a thousand dollars a month
every
every month yeah then 2020 came
and um due to the pandemic um those side
hustles that i mentioned
um just went through the roof yeah um so
between
january and july of this year um i was
able to pay off
19 grand wow wow yeah just
just by just submitting to the to the
process
um and so i've you know it's it's been
it's been amazing
the whole journey a little bit circular
but when you applied it it worked it
applies yeah i mean
for me i mean once i'm all in i'm all in
but i have to test the waters and yeah
that's with everything that i do
i hear you um very so analytical yeah
yes and one and once i
i saw that i was able to do it and
something that i enjoyed doing because i
definitely didn't enjoy
paying off debt sure you know um so once
i applied it to traveling
oh being able to to use this
it's the same concept but to do
something that i really enjoy
doing so what's your advice to someone
wanting to get out of debt
it's it's definitely it has nothing to
do with the numbers
um because when i looked at you know 39
000 dollars
um two years ago um a little over two
years ago
i was like i don't know when it's gone
you know when i'm gonna be able to do it
but
i'll do it eventually um it's all about
the mentality
it's all about um believing you can so
you take steps
right right and one of the things that
i've heard you mention on the podcast a
lot
is um is you went you know you went at
what you focus
on yep you know so um but i learned that
it's not that's not just like a
philosophy it's not just something that
sounds good like you literally when when
you're focusing on it
other opportunities come up you start i
mean i i had
um since i started focusing on it i had
two promotions at work and two uh
two raises um so my and and
the reason why i got the first promotion
was because i told myself okay if i want
to do this i have to make some more
money so i
actually started you know digging into
the job openings and stuff like that and
um
and got a job that i probably wouldn't
have applied for if i wasn't
out there looking for it and same with
the side hustles that's amazing you
became hyper intentional
oh you became very intentional
absolutely and uh not only did you get
your money back
uh you gave yourself a a promotion in
life yes
you know on another path man i'm proud
of you well done uh
seriously bro you have to be proud i
really do we're proud of you very much
absolutely got a copy of chris's book
for you everyday
millionaires that'll definitely need be
the next uh thing to be intentional
about
yes right next chapter in your story
that's the goal i'm trying i'm racking
my brain trying to find that quote that
when when a man or woman is focused and
has a goal
uh heaven and earth will move to cause
them to make it happen
you know it's just like everything
starts to collude collide
in your benefit when you're aiming at
something when you're aiming at nothing
it all just seems to wander away from
you all these opportunities go to
somebody else yes
but they seem to collide on you when
there's something
uh in the spiritual realm that when you
just focus on something it causes things
to happen
and and the thing is a lot of things um
there were i had plans for things to
work out in a certain way
it didn't work out in any way that i've
done but it actually
it worked out better better you know so
it's almost like there's a conspiracy
behind the scenes to work to cause you
to win
right yeah because i definitely didn't
plan on a pandemic i definitely didn't
know that
you know but no nor prospering from it
exactly you know you know
so well done sir very well done thanks
for coming all the way from la man oh i
had to
very neat the way to do it for me after
after all of that all right
richard from los angeles 40 000 dollars
paid off
in 20 months making 55 to 90.
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
all right i didn't give it any practice
but we'll give it my best shot right
here
three two one
i'm dead free
well done sir well done yep young man
it is amazing how there is a conspiracy
in your
favor when you set a goal
and you commit to it it's not a dream
it's not a wish it's a goal because the
goal is just vision with work clothes on
right that's right
and it's amazing how the the the
conspiracy of heaven and earth
comes together like everything is like
angels are saying we need to get him
that job
you know and we got to get this
relationship straightened out now we
gotta get this thing
and things just start to happen to your
benefit because you create this
wake yeah of becoming a force of nature
yeah
it's very very interesting how that
really does work
and it really i've observed it a bunch
in 30 years
oh this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
thank you for joining us america open
phones at
ramsay 825-5225 is my co-host today here
on the air
reed is with us in richland washington
hey reid welcome to the dave ramsey show
gentlemen thanks for taking my call
today sure man what's up
so i'm 35 my wife's 33
have three kids eight three and one
um basically to try to sum it up bought
our first home
about 10 years ago it was a duplex
rental property type of
property lived in one side rent rented
the other out
i'm kind of a fixer-upper sweat equity
entrepreneurial type
person saw an opportunity at another
cheap property
after we were in the duplex for about
five or six years
bobbed this other house picked it up and
recently with the high market we was
able to sell it for a pretty substantial
profit
and move back into our duplex um
after selling another property if that
makes sense yeah how many kids you got
how many kids you got three kids
and when you said when you uh started
all this stuff you did did you have kids
when you started all this stuff no he
did not he did not
so moving back in the duplex wasn't as
fun as you thought it might have been
it's cozier it's cozier um that's not
that i heard your wife shoes but i have
a
yeah i have an awesome wife though and
she she does above and beyond
um during that time me and my wife also
have completed her bachelor's degrees
online
while i worked full time and she's
taking care of kids
so great it's been a process
yeah so we still have a remaining
mortgage balance on the duplex of around
a hundred thousand
is what we owe left on it if uh okay
hundred thousand let's round it
up um we sold the other property
netted a profit after realtor fees after
everything of about 147
000 and so we already have some money
set aside that's been our
i guess you'd call it emergency fund
it's about three to five months
worth of savings um
we did say things a little bit backwards
we only incurred a little bit of school
debt while
me working full-time and taking care of
children of about
twenty thousand yeah what's your
question both degrees
well my question is with 147 000
um we're looking at possibly you know
obviously finding another primary
residence in the future
we could take 100 of that 147 000
pay off the rest of the duplex that is
going to maintain a rental property for
us for
a long time is how i see it um
and have some money left over to put
down as a down payment on the next
property
i guess my question is is is it
worthwhile to just pay off the rental
property
or because it's going to be a rental
property would it behoove me to
um buy something else with as much
contrary to what you've been doing for
your entire life
what we have found is that the people
who build wealth are the ones that get
out of debt and stay out of debt that is
the shortest path
to wealth building it's not keeping
around debt
and or figuring out that some debt is
good and some debt is bad and all that
bull crap
okay so bottom line is is if if i'm you
my goal is to take every dollar i can
get my hands on
and have a paid for house and i paid for
everything
as soon as possible now if that means
keeping the duplex so it takes a few
years to pay off the house or a few
years to pay off the duplex because you
put 147 000
on the house that's fine or if it means
i'm selling the duplex taking the equity
out of it
putting it with the 147 yep paying cash
for a house
then i'm going to start saving to pay
cash for my next rental and avoiding
debt from this point forward
either one of those plans will work for
me that's exactly right and reid you are
hearing
from a man that i know of that owns the
most real estate
possible i i know dave i know it's hard
for real estate i know his passion for
it
but i also know his philosophy and that
means with cash
and so in this and i read i hear it in
you you
you got the propensity for some stupid
uh that going on meaning
and as far as jumping out and grabbing
more property and more and this and that
you said you like getting your hands on
things and working on it what i want you
to do is get your hands on your future
and like dave said one or two ways
either hold on to the duplex
and that's going to be the slowest route
i'm going to microwave this bad boy i'm
going to sell the duplex
and take that money along with the money
you have saved get in a home
cash and pay cash for this thing and now
moving forward i'm not doing
anything debt related i don't care
who it's from how good of an idea or how
great of a property is
if i don't have cash there's no chance
of me taking that risk
so period i did that myself
when i was 28 years old i went broke
first thing we did was we rented for two
years and then we saved up and we paid
cash for a house
um then i saved up paid cash for my
first rental
that go round now i had four million
dollars with real estate before i went
broke
but it was all leveraged and i lost it
all right but my first rental
was about 32 years old and when you have
a paid for rental
and you do not have a house payment and
you start making just a little bit of
money
and you get to keep it all except the
dadgum government's part
right but the rest of it is yours you're
not sending a bunch of it to a bank it
does not take long to buy the next
rental
and by the way both of those rentals for
cash then cash flow like crazy
and that cash starts piling up you get a
snowball going here
in your favor rental snowball rent rates
i mean i got so much rent coming in
nowadays that i can buy another piece of
property
once a month right from the rent that's
coming in but how many properties did
you had before you
would it all fell in at the height of
your real estate back in the day
well i've owned over 2 000 in my life
but i'm trying to think that
the uh i probably owned uh probably only
about a hundred
a hundred yeah so you went from lost to
zero i lost them all yeah
yeah or sold them all to keep from
losing one of the two but
i mean they all went in that deal when i
got turned up on my face out of my own
stupidity because i had the propensity
which you said the propensity for
stupidity and i
i did it with zeros on the end man i
don't i don't do anything half butt and
when i do stupid i even go wide open you
know so
um that's what i did so it took
the the second go around was not the
hair the second go around was the
tortoise that's right
yeah and and that's what we're talking
about reed is what we're describing to
you is making your hair curl because
you're just like oh god that sounds so
slow
it is yup it's also the wisest route
it's also the shortest route
the best way to get rich quick is get
rich slow yes sir tyler's with us
tyler is in michigan hey tyler what's up
in your world good how about you dave
and chris nice to talk to you guys
you too man how can we help yeah um
i'm 29 years old and i have tried to get
real good grades
on um my retirement i
currently have about 140 000 in my
retirement account through my work
in my 401k and i am looking to max it
out
um starting this year um at 19.5 a year
i can put in
yeah and i didn't know is it best to
put all of it in one lump sum at the
beginning of the year or
pay the max out per month into my 401k
this year this year that we're just
coming out of is a really good example
to test you on this
all right mathematically if you're gonna
leave it alone in a retirement account
and you should be leaving it alone if
you're gonna leave it alone five or ten
years
it's always better to go in all in as
fast as you can because the money starts
working sooner
but emotionally sometimes that'll give
you a throat punch
imagine a world called january of 2020
and you put all in and what did it do
in march 20th the stock market
dove remember yeah right little pandemic
crash we had going there remember that
like
the world is coming to an end oh my god
remember that okay yeah oh yeah and if
you go pull up the dow jones industrial
average
for this year or s p 500 chart for the
year 2020 you'll see january coming
along
and about the time you would have maxed
your 401k
it fell off a cliff and if you can't
emotionally stomach that
you would not be where you would be
today which is
by the way after it fell off that cliff
it climbed steadily back up the mountain
and about 65 days or whatever it was
later it was back but nobody reported on
that in the news
and today you'd be sitting with a nice
rate of return
having invested it all in january but
the road that you would have taken would
have been thrilling
[Laughter]
mathematically mathematically is the
right thing to do emotionally you got to
be able to ride it
you got to be able to do the ride this
is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
[Applause]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice chris
hogan ramsey personality
is my co-host today we're taking your
calls about your life and your money
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five now next week uh in
preparation for christmas we will be
doing
our annual giving show
it is one of the more popular shows we
do and we devote an entire day of
shows to giving stories stories where
you call in and tell about the time that
you were able to help someone able to
give able to be outrageously generous
or sometime that you received something
that means someone else was giving it's
still a giving story we want to
promote and encourage outlandish
outrageous generosity and so if you have
a great
giving story or receiving story
to help someone be inspired about
generosity
then you just go you just email kelly at
dave on
air at ramseysolutions.com
dave on air at ramseysolutions.com just
put giving story in the subject line
tell a little bit about the story
keller will get back to you we don't
tell you what to say or anything like
that but we just line the calls up
so that we can get you lined up on
the air and chris we've had some great
giving stories
over the years we had two of them in
house this year
one each of our team members a thousand
team members we gave them
250 bucks each yes with the requirement
that they find
find someone in their life it could be a
family member it could be a
friend it could be even an acquaintance
yeah
uh that was affected by the pandemic
this year and was struggling and hurting
and uh in some way just be outrageously
generous with that 250 dollars
uh and we had some wonderful stories
come back on that people
are able to find all kinds of situations
where 250 dollars just completely
changes rock the world and i'm going to
tell you i haven't heard a few of the
stories it's one of those i get
goosebumps just because
uh we've had single moms be impacted
you've had people that
uh with health issues that have been
impacted that truly
uh are gonna have a different type of
holiday season uh because of that
and i can't wait for us to see the whole
compiled list
uh just the ripple effect of that dave
uh because once you have that mindset in
that heart
what happens is you begin to to make a
difference
and you can talk about it or be about it
and uh through
through ramsey solutions we were able to
be about being a blessing to people
yeah yeah and the second thing we were
able to do was we took some of our
christmas party budget this year
and we used it to buy old
bad debt and we bought 10 million
dollars worth of medical debt
and uh old car repossession debt and
credit card debt
eight thousand accounts and uh like i
said there's roughly
970 of us something like that it right
about about a thousand of us and so we
gave everybody eight
people to contact and tell them that
their debt
was forgiven and the stories that have
come out of that
were absolutely amazing it's jesus
birthday god sent his son so that we're
forgiven
we're christians and so we like
celebrating that and uh
we do it loudly and boldly and so we're
gonna forgive
your debt 10 million dollars worth
and some of the stories back on that the
amount of tears
oh are incredible listen i don't know
why this hasn't been picked up by a
major news network
you all oh yeah yeah well i know it's
ridiculous
but but to hear people you got to hear
this now
so this is old debt it could have been
hanging around for five years or more
right where people haven't been able to
make progress on it and to get a phone
call
not a collection call but to get a phone
call
from somebody to tell you that that
that's been forgiven in jesus's name
you can't imagine the responses we got
you can't imagine the relief that people
felt to have this thing that's been
around their neck
or this thing that's been in the back of
their mind or their spirit for it to be
removed
was amazing yeah absolutely amazing 10
million
off the books gone like erased
uh and we had dollar amounts anywhere
from 500 up to 15 to 20 000.
but it didn't matter it was the you
could hear the joy in the people's
voices
uh and i tell you that's a job i would
take all day long yeah to make those
kind of phone calls
i said call people told them their dad's
forgiven yeah that'd be a great job all
day
but uh it's amazing it was amazing it's
interesting too calling because i had
like 10 people to call
and uh everybody else had eight but i
got 10 because it's kind of like my
company so
um i really and i never got a person all
i got i got three
i think i got four voicemails and left
the voicemail and then i got
um a bunch of disconnected numbers i did
two yeah and so
the uh because obviously if you're in
collections you don't pick up a strange
phone
no i don't pick up a strange phone
number anyway yes if you're not my
caller id i just figure you're stupid i
don't
need anybody calling me so boom you're
gone uh you can get touch with me some
other way
because i just don't take phone calls
that much anyway but anyway i and i'm
if you're in collections i suppose it's
that way now yeah you know
the phone up because you know some duper
trying to hassle you right
so then they open up their voicemail and
it's me on there
going one of them was 36 thousand
dollars
wow hard that forgiven that was pretty
cool
but i have no idea i didn't talk to the
guy but um i just left him voicemail but
some of them are calling back into
the ramsey concierge team and they're
hearing the stories yeah too so maybe
maybe some of mine got through but
you kind of got a feeling what it's like
to be a collector
uh-huh you know you got a bunch of beady
this number has been disconnected you
know right and that's what you do all
day
yeah dave you know i used to do that
back in the day you did back in the day
i would give out money at the first of
the month and then i got
so much what does that mean
[Laughter]
i used to make phone calls there are
people still in counseling they even
knock on doors
oh no back in the day yeah yeah oh
i know better now yeah i'm on the right
side of the process
i'm preventive of medicine yeah well
you're yeah you're not yes um
yes you're not on the dark side
of the light yeah i did i really did but
the cool thing was is not only do we
call them and leave them that voicemail
they're going to receive the letters
from us
confirming it and you all it was just a
blessing and i just
i want to encourage you out there
especially this time of year you have
people that are struggling
and they look like everything's okay uh
on the outside the face is okay and
they're not
stuff like how's everything going just
fine they'll even tell you
i'm okay or everything's all right i
truly you know those people
and i want you to make an impact in
asking and praying for them
but also giving in small and big ways uh
and
if some of you are going anywhere where
there are valets
or servers or any anybody in the
hospitality world
they all are operating on about 20 of
their normal income
because it's just their lives have been
screwed this year by the shutdown
and so you know you really somebody
delivering a pizza to your house
you really need to throw a big tip on
yeah can i tell you a cool story take a
tip
triple tip quadruple tip everywhere you
go during the holidays especially
real quick there's an fpu class uh uh
one of our team members sent this to me
they were meeting and doing the social
distance but they were still doing their
class
well they called and ordered pizza and
this guy brings pizza to the door
they give him a copy of dave's book
total mini makeover and retire inspired
but there's an envelope inside of it
they had collected a tip for this guy
and gave him four hundred dollars
okay the delivery guy and he's sitting
there holding the book in the cash and
he goes are you serious
and they were like absolutely this is
what this class is about we want you to
read these books but be blessed
yeah and that was really cool they got
it on video it's awesome
we're gonna do giving stories like that
next week send us yours
send us yours at dave on air at
ramseysolutions.com
and we'll get you lined up to be one of
the callers next week on the giving show
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage
that would meet our needs chm is not
health insurance
but it is christians helping other
christians by sharing
each other's medical bills the medical
bill sharing from chm
was exactly the way the website
described it there were no surprises
no bait and switch no hidden agenda
chm did everything they said they would
by sharing all of our eligible needs
we like that it's a non-profit ministry
and that we were being better stewards
of our money
all while helping other families
established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm
is here to meet the needs of your
growing family or small business
get started today and check us out at
chministries.org
backslash budget that's chministries.org
backslash budget we absolutely believe
in it
[Music]
so
we were talking about the 10 million
dollars in debt we paid off
anytime someone becomes debt free
everything but the house or everything
including the house something happens
inside of you sometimes it's a real
dramatic
you can just hear it click you know yeah
and
sometimes it's a little more subtle and
it's just kind of
smooth but either way it's the sound of
chains
dropping because the borrower is
slave to the lender when i hear a
debt-free scream i always ask
who the cheerleaders were because
getting
to be a freed former slave
requires some cheerleading and a lot of
motivation and a lot of scratching and
clawing and a lot of scrappy
so if you're ready to make some progress
on your debt you need some motivation
join ramsey plus and you'll go through
our step-by-step money plan
with people just like you
who are trying to get out of debt it's
good to have some
comrades and arms some a band of
brothers
to fight beside as you're doing this
stuff our most popular class financial
peace university is of course part of
ramsey plus
you connect directly with people who can
hold you accountable
and encourage you to stick with the plan
and stay away from the
as chris says stay away from stupid
it'll sneak up on you
as a ramsey plus member you get the
tools the practical tips you need to pay
off your debt
fast the fastest possible way
so that the future you're working toward
will be there for you you can get out of
debt
and you don't have to do it alone join a
financial peace university class after
you become a ramsey plus member to start
your free trial of ramsey plus and join
a class
you text the word join to 33789
join 233 7
8 9. taylor is in houston texas hey
taylor welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi thanks for taking my call today sure
what's up
uh yes so my husband and i are in baby
step two
so we started in september of this year
we've paid off about six grand or so
first
or so so yeah and so the next question
is um we still have a lot of debt to go
but we know we need to get rid
of one of our vehicles that we are
upside down on
uh my question is how to best go about
that so we're probably about
40 4500 4 000 upside down
due to a private or to a private sale so
do i
put that money towards just principal
payments or do i say that
into savings until it's time to sell and
then apply it to the loan or does it not
really matter
doesn't matter either one's fine and i
would count that
if you if that's a car you're selling i
would take 4 500
upside down amount put that number in
your debt snowball
okay so just put that in the nutshell so
i can pay
so okay so putting this again snowball
so we have that
smaller than that at this point so
should we just uh
you have all one payment um on snowball
we have um a few credit cards that are
below that amount yeah you'll knock them
out before you do this car deal probably
okay and then i would knock out the card
then i would knock out the car
save up the five grand to get out of the
car right or pay it down five grand
either one
get rid of the car and of course you got
to get your little beater car to get
around in too right
yeah well we're just going to go in one
car because he gets a work truck so i
work from home
like yeah he can just take my car to get
there if he needs to
okay that makes me feel better because
putting that money in savings kind of
scares me because art doesn't really
scare me i'm like ooh i could apply this
here because we've gone super crazy
we're doing uber east and we're doing
all of that fun stuff
so we're really excited but it's really
scary just to put that money aside and
then apply it all at the end
yeah you're doing so good yeah you guys
are doing a great job yeah keep working
your debt snowball
like keep that money as it comes in keep
it moving directly toward the debt
everything but a thousand dollars
and what that's going to do is help you
stay on the path so taylor proud of you
all
this is the time of year don't let your
guard down stupid is lurking around
every corner so
be intentional yeah um
i've also noticed you can't let your
guard down on food this time of year
um food and money
why you had to get all churches
yeah i'm on salads right now which is
frustrating
because salad isn't the food salad is a
promissory note
like more food is coming and so i'm
having to adjust my mindset
especially if you're from the south
where your salads are certain you put
gravy on salad in the south
[Laughter]
see i think we found your problem yeah
jocelyn is in sacramento
hey jocelyn what's up hi dave hi
um chris how are you guys great how can
we help
i'm i'm calling actually because i'm a
little bit in a
financial situation and i was really
really hoping you guys can help me out
so me and my husband um purchased our
first home
um last year in november and now
i've lost my job and we literally cannot
make ends meet
and i just kind of wanted to see what
was your input um we did get the house
evaluated
and actually at a lesser value now
um and then the forbearance that we're
currently on
adds on to it actually so um
that's kind of the situation i mean i
kind of want to know you owe more on the
house than it's worth
yes why because you haven't been paying
payments through the since november
uh no not since november since uh april
okay both of you lost your job right now
what was that both of you lost your jobs
just my husband i mean just myself my
husband's the only one providing right
now and
well uh he makes 55 000 a year
and how much is your house payment 600.
good lord what did you make
i bought the same thing that he did you
had a high house payment before
i know it's like ultra high okay yeah so
it's
it's it's a little scary um we do have a
little bit of money put
like for savings what does the what does
the forbearance sound like you're
not you're just not paying payments
right yeah i'm not making any payments
on it
yeah exactly because at the end of the
day you're still responsible for that
money
yeah so you have you talked to the
lender
have you tried to sell the house on a
short sale yes
yes so we we um we were actually in the
causes of a short sale
however the agent that was supposed to
be helping us he wasn't
very honest he actually uh falsified
some paperwork
and i no longer felt comfortable with
him so i actually terminated that
um that process because yeah you need to
start the process over with a good real
estate agent get rid of this house
because this is not going to end well
you can't just sit and not pay payments
indefinitely
eventually this is going to get the wall
yeah and you've got to work through the
lender
to get approved for a short sale um
so i was going to say jocelyn not only
do you have to work through that process
you also need to gain agreement on
what's going to happen on the dollar
amount that is short
like they need to give it in full
writing you need a real estate agent
that has experience
in dealing in short sales what you want
to do a loan without i mean a short sale
without recourse
that's right you're not in the on the
hook for the balance
what's what kind of one is this fha va
or conventional
it's an fha okay all right uh so here
here's what you've got to do
uh you need to get online at
daveramsey.com click on elp
for real estate find an endorsed local
provider in your area
that we recommend they've got the heart
of a teacher interview two or three of
them over the phone
and ask who's got some short sale
experience
short sales are not as hot right now
because the market's so hot
even in sacramento the market's so hot
i'm really surprised you're upside down
on this house it's very unusual in that
market
and so um either way i'm going to get
this house on the market
and get it sold short sale and you got
to put
a lot of effort and a lot of time and a
lot of energy with the agent into
causing that to happen
because this is going to not sneak up on
you it's going to creep
up on you and knock you in the back of
the head this is not going to be pretty
you have got to deal with this and so
get this stinking house sold
if you do not get it sold your worst
case scenario is if you don't
pay payments they're eventually just
going to take it
it is california and it takes forever to
execute a foreclosure there
so you may be three or four years behind
before they get around to it
particularly in a pandemic so
but that doesn't mean it's not gonna
come and all of a sudden
so to speak you're going to have a
problem and it's not really
all of a sudden so let's get this thing
sold and let's get you re-employed
and then don't get into a house payment
the stinking 50
of your take-home pay again that was
just nuts
even before you lost your job this is
the dave ramsey show
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local
communities whether your goals are to
get an education
serve your country or have a better life
the army national guard can help get you
there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
so
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage
justin and heather are with us hey guys
how are you good
welcome where do you guys live attica
michigan awesome
good to have you welcome to nashville
and how much debt have you paid off
seventy two thousand two hundred and
sixty dollars all right
love it and how long did that take you
eight and a half months
good for you wow and your range of
income during that time
um well we're self-employed so in 2019
we had eighty thousand 000 and this year
we're projected to make between 115 and
120.
wow very good excellent what do you guys
do for a living
um i'm a carpenter home remodeling and
stuff like that
okay very cool so tell us what did you
pay off
well we had two thousand dollars worth
of couches
fifty five hundred dollars for a classic
car sixty six hundred dollars for a dirt
bike
ninety eight hundred dollars for another
classic car ten thousand five hundred
dollars for a dump trailer and 37
thousand
eight hundred dollars for a student loan
wow sounds like somebody had some toys
well yeah well i'll take um full
responsibility for that one hers was
only the student loan
i wasn't thinking about her yeah right
[Laughter]
that's so great somebody has to say so
you might you must have had some money
in savings or you sold something
um we sold about 24 000 worth of stuff
what did you sell we sold the 54 hudson
hornet
i and justin sold the brand new dirt
bike that he got he didn't even get to
ride it
oh my gosh um since we're in michigan we
bought it in november
and it was gone by the end of march so
no time to uh ride in the winter yeah
yeah
and then we also sold uh some tools that
he had laying around
and a boat oh wow okay wow so you
sacrificed some real stuff
here justin what happened what caused
you all to get this serious
well you know stuff is just stuff you
know i look at the kids
every day and i don't want to you know i
want to give them
a means you know show them teach them
you know so they can provide for
themselves and better themselves
and i think um you know with owning our
business
uh by the time the end of 2019 came we
had all those loans
and joss was working for a contractor
that when he paid it paid really well by
getting him to pay was a job in itself
and so trying to float paying our
subcontractors
keeping the business going with buying
materials and the expenses for it and
then also paying ourselves
the weight of that got really heavy and
we were working basically for nothing
and i and i think that the other thing
too is we realized we had our priorities
wrong
and that we needed to put god first and
once we put god first in our life then
all that stuff
just became stuff it didn't become the
source of contentment that we were
looking for
and so once we did that it was like the
floodgates opened and it's like you say
you know when god realizes you can
manage a small
then he gives you more and as the year
went along
we couldn't believe like the profits
that we were getting from these jobs
and we're like did we always get this
much money and just blow it or like
we know the answer to that question yeah
and we had a few bumps up along the road
um in
july i got into a car accident and i so
we were
pretty thick into it we're really close
to being done and justin had an 85 chevy
suburban laying around
i that had no air conditioning the radio
didn't work
and i it was it was not my first choice
of car but
um i've actually named her bertha there
you go and drove her with pride because
we were not going to get another loan
and actually we ended up getting the car
back and seeing the progress that we had
with
so little left on the student loan i was
like i don't care about getting it fixed
up
like let's take the money that we're
going to use to fix up the car
and i don't have to see the outside of
it it's fine on the inside and we tacked
it on because we just saw how fast
it would progress like getting out of
debt sooner so
when originally started we thought it
was going to be two years and i
convinced him it would only take 18
months
and then it turned into a year and then
as we just kept going and just kept
piling and
looking at everything that we could sell
uh it just turned into eight and a half
months and we were done
it kind of it kind of turned into a game
i mean once you turn loose of things
yeah emotionally then it's like okay how
can we what's the
it's like tetris working where can we
set this money to make it get
to make this debt snowball roll yep and
i was listening to your show and you had
um
someone on and he said something that
really struck a chord it was that god's
not a transactional god he's a
relational god
and that you know he's not just going to
give you the 70 thousand dollars but
when you commit to it
he finds so he gives you a way to do it
so justin had lots of opportunities for
work
we had all this stuff that became such a
burden became a blessing in a way
because it became
a means to get out of debt and get out
of uh the mess that we had made
very cool and justin you talk about your
kids being your motivation how many kids
do you all have we have three
how old are they um five and a half okay
almost four
and almost two huh so and and the stuff
is just stuff you don't you know okay i
don't have a brand new dirt bike i have
a
20 year old dirt bike i have a 25 year
old car it gets me to work the same way
that's right so what's it really matter
that's right
you got your priorities straight yep
well done how does it feel to be free
it's amazing when we sit and look at you
know
like all we have is just our house
payment you know it's just such a weight
lifted off
and you know being able to show that for
the kids too you know we're starting to
teach the five-year-olds all right about
giving and saving and spending and
she's got her chores around the house
and she just went and bought her first
toy from earning her eight dollars of
dishwasher yeah i love it you guys are
incredible well done heroes
very proud of you what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
well being on the same page yes yes
because we've actually known about you
for 10 years and we were ramsey-ish
for 10 of those years we actually met
you seven years ago at your other
building
and we get on board but then you know
doing this is
it's a commitment and you know like
i it was something that we didn't think
we'd be able to do
and we thought we were better than the
average person because we did have a
thousand dollars in our emergency fund
we did have a loose budget and you know
we would get a loan we pay it off
early but then we go and get another one
and then we go and get another one and
okay well after this one we're going to
get into it and we never really did and
then finally when all that kind of just
weighed down you're like okay we got it
we gotta do it
gotta knock it out now gotta do the
recipe the way that it's made yeah they
kind of get discussed that after some
point yeah and it's just like
game on you're working until all hours
of the night yeah
nothing to show i feel like a rat in a
wheel
just run run run run get nowhere yep
well well done you guys
very very proud of you we got a copy of
chris hogan's book for you
everyday millionaires that needs to be
the chapter
in your next chapter in your story and
the kiddos join you for the debt free
scream what are their names and ages
this is addie and she's five this is
emerson and she's almost two
and this is hudson and he is almost four
wow
you got a house full this is awesomeness
right here
well you've changed your family tree
guys i'm very proud of you
very well done very well done all right
justin heather
addie hudson and emmy 72 000 paid off in
eight and a half months making 80 to
115. they sold everything that wasn't
nailed down
count it down let's hear a great debt
free scream
three two one we're debt-free
well done you guys oh wow
very very well done absolutely these
young people these young kids are going
to have a whole different future now
mom and dad have taken back control and
have a path
and have clarity and that's fantastic
you guys just started a legacy
and it's amazing it is amazing you're
looking at a family tree that got
changed those of you watching on youtube
and
i got to tell you that's a real thing it
really happens
you know rachel cruz was born the year
that we went broke
and we started understanding these
things and
of course our older sister denise was a
toddler our marriage is hanging on by a
thread that's a year our life was
changed
we said never again never
again and um now rachel's got kids
success
so and that you know the family tree
changes yeah you are you are changing it
but you have to make a decision
and you have to draw a line in the sand
and go that's it we're done let's run
we're done
and you don't have to drive a 20 year
old something the rest of your life but
you do until you don't
you got to make those sacrifices it's a
requirement you got to do it until you
don't got to do it well that's it
you pay cash for it as you go that's the
way it works very well done you guys
proud of you this is the dave ramsey
show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture of the day second timothy
3 16-17
all scripture is breathed out by god and
profitable for teaching for reproof
for correction and for training in
righteousness
that the man of god may be complete
equipped for every good work
zig ziglar says what you get by
achieving your goals is not as important
as what you've become
by achieving your goals open phones at
825 5225 chris hogan ramsey personality
is my
co-host today here on the air you jump
in we'll talk triple eight
eight two five five two two five fort
knox kentucky david
is on the line hi david welcome to the
dave ramsey show
hi dave and chris thanks so much for
taking my call sure man what's up
hey so i am if everything goes right
starting law school this upcoming fall
uh now unfortunately i don't have the
money to cash flow it but i
am in the national guard and they do
offer a student loan repayment program
if i re-enlist
now i have money for this upcoming year
to max out my roth ira and i guess my
question is should i
still invest and rely on that student
loan repayment plan for the guard or
should i
stop investing and start saving to pay
off law school
well law school is an investment also
a better investment than a mutual fund
so i would stop all
investing in cash flow everything and
you'll get the money anyway
from the national guard and then that'll
just cash flow the next semester or the
next year
okay well so the the student loan
repayment program i won't really see
the full fruition of it until about five
years after law school
so i guess that eight year time frame is
just worrisome but
that makes sense why will you not see it
until five years after
so uh in order for it to actually be
applied to my law school loans i'd have
to re-enlist after law school's done
oh start paying on it for another year
so it'd be at least four years before
any money okay okay i got you yeah i'm
gonna do everything i can to cash flow
law school then
and then when that money comes it'll
just be a repayment at that point right
yeah absolutely because i mean they're
going to do that program they're going
to follow through on that
without a doubt yeah that might be that
that might
that might change your plan a little bit
but either way that's that's what i'm
going to do
and congratulations well done and thank
you for your willingness to serve
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five zak is in redmond washington hi
zach welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey dave how's it going better than i
deserve man what's up
sounds good hey uh so my wife and i
in the last year recently bought our
first property um we graduated two years
ago
and and our mortgage broker
reached out to us and said that she
could save us like 400
by i guess interest rates being low and
all that
um she said something in her explanation
about
rolling over all of the money we paid
into the mortgage
into this new one and how that made her
not have to
uh i guess get the house reassessed
um i didn't quite understand everything
and so
i don't unders i don't know if the four
hundred dollars is all we're looking at
or if there's other i guess side effects
fha loan yes it is okay
what she's proposing is what's called a
streamline loan
and the interest rate is a little higher
than marketplace interest rates are and
then
um
with the interest rate being a little
higher they offset that and they
don't charge closing costs
that make sense not sure not totally
so i'll tell you our original loan was
like 585
at uh 3.8 something percent um and she's
proposing like 2.99
would be the new thing um i guess in my
head
it it made sense that with such a lower
interest rate on such a high amount of
money
it would end up costing us less but i
obviously i don't know
what i'm saying is the interest rate you
have today is what
uh 3.875 i believe and they're quoting
you what on the new one
uh two point eight seven five or two
point nine
okay so one percent credit and you have
any closing costs on the quote you got
um she said that they were going to
cover any upfront costs
and but i did take a look at the
she said it would cost about 3 000 on
the tail end of the loan like i just
paid over time
oh they just rolled the closing costs in
okay so it's not a streamline
okay streamlines they don't charge
closing costs on and the interest rate
is higher but 2875 is not a not an above
market rate so
that's about a market rate and so that
puts you in pretty good stead there
um so you're saving one percent on
five hundred thousand dollars which is
five thousand dollars
a year in interest
okay so and if it costs you three
thousand dollars on the back
it was worth it
okay so this is absolutely something we
should do that's what i'm hearing
well the scenario just the the scenario
dave just laid out for you
is the scenario you should do i don't
know what your person was talking about
uh sounds like they're talking around
you instead of to you
so i'm going to reach out if i'm you i'm
going to reach out talk to churchill
talk with them about what you're looking
to do and understand the difference yeah
call churchill mortgage and get a
different quote
and see what they can quote you and see
how that compares and also
try to get a little bit better
explanation as to what you're getting
into
the typical thing you'll have is you
will have some closing costs and if you
have the equity
you can roll the closing costs in
meaning you borrow them
they come off the back end of the loan
is what amounts to they are they're
added to the loans
is all it is and that's okay to do if
you're in baby step two it's not a
problem at all
but but you're because you're saving
your has nothing out of pocket or
virtually nothing out of pocket
and you're saving five thousand dollars
a year in interest
uh and you can go ahead and you should
go ahead and make it a 15 year fixed
which means you're probably not going to
save 400 a month anymore
right but but you are saving 400
a month in interest it'll just be going
towards the principal that's right and
you're getting rid of 16 years
and also with fha we got to keep our
eyes open you all because now
uh that pmi private mortgage insurance
can be on those loans for life okay so
you got to go into it you got to get the
right people on your side so you know
what product you're dealing with
and what makes sense for you yeah that
makes that that's exactly right chris is
in milwaukee wisconsin
hi chris welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey guys how are you better than i
deserve sir how can i help
okay so i have a bridge account
slash investing question for you guys um
thanks to both of you my wife and i paid
off about 400
000 in student loans here
wow um together we make
about 400k and so
my question is you know right now i
maxed out my 401k
ross of 19k and we have all this extra
money
uh coming in um
and trying to figure out where to put it
i have a combination of 300 000
in rollover and roth roth iras
and so my first question is a tax
question
i i have former employee 401ks that are
now in rollovers
can my wife execute the backdoor roth
and avoid the pro rata rule and then my
second question is is it even worth
doing any of that for the
for the backdoor off on her end
or both can do a back door roth and
their
pro rata really didn't get anything to
do with it when you do a back door wear
off yeah
sharon and i sharon and i do a backdoor
roth every year
got it so the rollover iras don't impact
that no they do not impact that at all
no okay got it and chris what baby step
are you on we're getting close on time
what baby step are you guys on right now
uh so we just want to figure out how to
invest the 15
and then we're gonna go start paying off
the house all right well and
the beauty of it is is doing the 15 this
is what i was getting at
do the 15 then you need to turn your
attention to the house
once the house is paid off now you can
begin but getting to fifteen percent of
four hundred is that a lot of
generations get there yeah yeah but
reach out get with the smart investor
pro and sit down i'm proud of you guys
wow uh getting rid of 400 000 student
loan debt's a big deal
absolutely slated man very very well
done
all right chris good show today thank
you sir it's fun james childs our
producer well done kelly daniel our
associate producer and phone screener
great show
i am dave ramsey your host we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace
christ jesus
[Music]
[Music]
you